with the single possible exception of
devil fruits swords are easily the
single most awesome and Powerful things
in all of One Piece so we're going to
rank the 13 strongest swords ever in the
story starting with Trafalgar lost
lethal blade kikoku and while you might
not expect the sword to be ranked very
high especially with that fluffy cross
guard it is actually one of the swords
that Del Demo's damage in the entire
story and that's because this
extraordinary blade has served law in
intense battles against strong Fighters
like Warlords and Emperors of the sea
plus law also uses kikoku in his
strongest attacks like this one here
which even broke through an entire
Island and we also know that this sword
is cursed which means that it was made
by an incredibly skilled Craftsman and
that it is nearly impossible for any
weak swordsman to use it because they
cannot control the will of the blade but
lost surgical blade of death is
certainly not the only cursed blade that
we will be seeing in this ranking and so
moving on from the surgeon's blade let's
discuss his sword owned by someone who
literally has done because at number 12
we have this skeleton's cane sword and
Brooke has actually named this Dapper
blade so solid mostly because he is able
to combine his icy cold Soul powers to
make the sword a devastating weapon in
combat and just like the previous sword
Soul solid has clashed with Emperors
like big mom and it has never let Brooke
down in over 50 years of graceful
swordsmanship also one more very
important thing to mention about salt
solid is that it has actually a
personality of its own now this is
common with many of the strongest swords
and the author has even drawn Brook's
sword as a wrinkly old man but this
sword is not even close to the insanely
powerful and famous blades later on in
this video however first next in a
ranking is one of the largest swords
ever used in the entire story no not
this one or even this one and I wish
someone actually used this sword but now
for now we have this enormous blade
right here because this is fungfried and
it is the only sword confirmed that the
entire story that has actually eaten a
devil fruit and because of this rare
ability it can actually transform from
its base sword form to a hybrid
snake-like blade and a full-blown
elephant form which is an absolutely
insane power that is completely wasted
by the most pitiful character in the
entire story so far because all I'm
saying is that if this sword was instead
used by an actual strong character it
could easily be one of the best swords
in the entire story because of its sheer
versability because you basically never
have to worry about losing your sword
because it could just transform and walk
next to you which would also be really
nice to see kind of show the connection
between the swordsman and his swords and
so while This Magnificent elephant sword
made a tremendous first impression the
next sword on his list has been a super
important part of the story for nearly 1
000 chapters enter the Sunday kotetsu
which of course is owned by our all
favorites roronoa Zorro now he
discovered this blade in chapter the 97
at a sword shop in loc town and
initially the shop owner actually
refused to allow anyone to take it or
even touch it because its previous
owners had all died however of course
Zorro was determined to prove himself
and challenge the blade itself and yes
this is of course yet another cursed
blade in our ranking but even after
earning the sword fair and square Zorro
initially struggles hard to control the
sendikitetsu's bloodless and this
actually goes to show us that a
swordsman using a cursed blade must give
extra Focus to the blade itself to
prevent it from cutting things that they
don't intend including themselves but
that's not all about this impressive
sword because in one piece many swords
are actually ranked based on their
exceptional Feats remarkable
craftsmanship and also just sheer power
and so the sandai kitetsu here is a
simply graded blade which is the lowest
of the swords that are actually ranked
though we still have to be honest and
say that these swords are still way
stronger than any average sword in the
store story however then about these
like standard great blades are 50
skillful great blades 21 great great
plates and finally the 12 Supreme gray
blades which of course we will get to as
well now you may already know about the
other two kitetsu blades there's the
first second and third one and
supposedly the sandai which means three
is the weakest of the three however I'm
going to exclude the nidai kitetsu from
this ranking since we have only briefly
glimpsed it in wano plus I actually
believe that due to zoro's countless
intense battles with the Sendai it may
as well have already surpassed the nidai
kitetsu in terms of strength which yes
is a real thing because swords can
actually get stronger in one piece based
on their wielder's hockey which we will
be discussing more with some of the top
drank swords later on in this video but
wait we're starting to go down a pretty
deep Rabbit Hole here and if we want to
do so we should go prepared which is why
I want to thank today's sponsor Bessie
to sum it up in a nutshell vessi makes
the perfect Urban shoe there comfy 100
waterproof which is great because I can
wear them on the beach and during rainy
season Japan and I've been very
impressed actually how durable these are
I actually usually go through shoes
quite quickly because I love walking
running around in them and doing stuff
like playing football in the street
probably too much but my first pair of
vessels have lasted over two years
actually of pretty much daily abuse on
my end so it was super nice to see that
they actually decided to sponsor me
because I was about to get a new pair of
these anyways and even if those get
dirty you can just Chuck them in the
washing machine and they come out
looking like new and best of all Bessie
looks amazing they come in a variety of
styles though I did really Vibe with
these white ones that will be just
perfect for Tokyo summer and right now
I've partnered up with vesi for Memorial
Day to get you up to 30 on a bunch of
different shoe styles using my link
vesi.com ahara and even if you happen to
watch this video a little bit later
you'll still get a very solid 15
discount on your order using the code
Ohara at checkout link in the
description below and now back to the
video walking down that rabbit hole and
while Sandy's curse makes it a blade to
be feared no sword on this ranking has
more personality than big mom's Napoleon
now this massive hat slash sword has
been combined with a piece of big mom's
own soul to make it a living breathing
creature it can grow to a truly massive
size and has clashed with countless
strong opponents including kaido meaning
that it has to be an insanely strong and
sturdy sword but even Napoleon hasn't
achieved something as impressive as this
next plate here which managed to leave a
scar on kaido himself because this is
Zorro's famous Waldo ichimonji one of
the three swords that he used to leave a
bloody wound on kaido during their
rooftop battle and this sword is the
closest to zoro's Heart since it is also
representation of his promise with his
childhood friend quina to become the
world's strongest swordsman however next
to its emotional significance to Zorro
the waduchimoji is actually also one of
the only 21 great great swords making it
one of the strongest blades ever now
many already believe that this is zoro's
most important sword because he's been
having it since he was a child and
personally I think he will make it even
stronger and it will eventually become
one of the highest ranking swords in the
story and yet all of that still doesn't
make it stronger than the next play in
this ranking because it has been around
for hundreds of years and was used by
the literal sword God himself and that
is none other than shusui which belong
to the legendary Samurai ryuma now Zorro
earned this blade after defeating the
zombie version of ryuma and even Zorro
immediately noticed that this blade was
heavy and Incredibly powerful this sword
is another of the 21 great great swords
but on top of it it is a legendary Black
Blade what is a Black Blade you ask well
that's an excellent question you see
there are actually only two of these
black blades confirmed in the entire
story so far and while we don't know
exactly how the process works to make
one we're being told that swords can
become black blades after countless
battles alongside their master in other
words undoubtedly this involves
incredible high levels of Hockey being
infused into the blades now sadly enough
Zorro actually couldn't keep shushui
forever because in chapter 954 he was
begged to return a tuano country because
it is considered a National Treasure but
Zara of course wouldn't give it up for
free and only agree to this in exchange
for another even stronger blades that
will of course be discussing a little
bit later in this ranking and now just
barely not making the cut of the top
five we have the infamous curse sword
the shodai kitetsu now this sword is
supposed to be the strongest of the
kitetsu lines and it's the very first
blade in this video which owns the
Supreme grade sword Rank and while we've
never officially seen this blade in the
story so far a common theory is that it
is actually being owned by this guy
right here because it has an incredibly
similar Hills rapping and cross guard to
the other two katetso blades and so
clearly just based on reputation it's
ranking and its likely owner this is
going to be an extremely powerful sword
that I cannot wait to actually see in
action which means that you should
definitely absolutely undoubtedly
subscribe to the channel so you don't
miss future videos discussing secrets of
the one piece worlds like when this
sword is finally revealed which now
already brings us into the top five
where we have a blade that you may
confuse for another famous character and
that is Ace because this is Ace but this
is also Ace which honestly would get a
little bit confusing around the house if
they were still alive so parenting
ticket number one so you still learn
something in this video probably don't
name your child after your favorite
weapon but for a long time we wondered
about the famous sword of the former
pirate king Goldie Roger many fans
believe that Roger actually gave his
sword to Shanks but it does turn out
that this is a completely different
sword on top of that we also recently
learned that it is one of the 12 Supreme
grade blades in a visual book written by
the author Oda and honestly that makes a
lot of sense because this badass Cutlass
is Roger's primary weapon that he used
to fight the strongest characters in the
entire story however it is a little bit
unclear if the sword is a black blade or
not since it is never mentioned and it's
kind of hard to tell from the manga
anime like could just be hockey but I
wouldn't be surprised honestly if it was
because of the many Titanic battles that
Raja must have fought during his life
with this and who did Roger fight in
many of these epic clashes well that
would be the former World's Strongest
Man Whitebeard with his world famous
naginata murakumugiri and while this is
the only technically non-sword in this
ranking it is undeniably one of the
strongest blades ever forged of course
this is also a supreme great blade just
like his rival sword and Whitebeard
masterfully used murakumogiri in
combination with his trema fruit to
produce attacks capable of destroying
entire Islands but with this we're
moving from the strongest Blades of the
previous generation into the top three
which are all still being used in the
story today and how do you think this
top 3 will turn out in the end well
we're gonna kick it off with Griffin the
faithful blade of the one armed
swordsman Shanks and even today there's
a lot of mystery surrounding this sword
as there is around this character but
there is some surprising information
that was recently revealed about it like
did you know that Shanks can actually
coat this sword with a fiery Aura I'm
not sure if that means haki or some
other elemental powers but
Dan cannot wait to see that and you also
may not have realized that Shanks did
not actually start the story with this
sword because in chapter 1 Shanks
actually uses a sword with this hand
guard which is quite distinctly
different from Griffin now this could
mean that Oda just didn't have the final
design in mind during chapter one or
maybe Shanks just obtained Griffin later
on in the later years between chapter
one and when we actually first see him
using it in chapter 234 now we actually
don't know the official in world ranking
for Griffin but it would not surprise me
like at all to learn that this would
also be a supreme great sword
considering that Shanks uses it
basically any time that he makes a move
in the story ever but then with Griffin
out of the way at number two we have
enma and in a little bit of a Twist I
think it's sibling blades Amino habakiri
now I'm actually putting both of these
together because they should essentially
be on the same level since they were
both used by the former Samurai Odin
however since we have the most
experience with enma let's discuss this
one in more detail and we learned just
how monstrous this sword is right after
Zorro traded shoe suite for it and
that's because by just holding the sword
enma will suck the life force out of the
user which can literally kill you if you
aren't even strong enough to use it
which forces Zoro to use all of his
hockey so that he can fully control the
blade and use it to its full potential
heck it basically forced Zoro to learn
Advanced Conquest hockey during his
final battle against kaido's right-hand
man king plus Zorro used enma and his
other two swords as well to block one of
the strongest attacks we've seen in the
entire series and while it is currently
still ranked as a great great sword
which is so stupid to say we're told
that if Zorro is able to turn enma into
a Black Blade then it would probably be
considered one of the Supreme great
swords which the same could probably be
said of amino how about Kitty
unfortunately that sword is not being
used by someone as strong as Zoro at the
time so it might just not be relevant in
the story in the future so now let's
reveal the single strongest blade in the
entire story and yes no surprises here
it is of course the black light of the
strongest swordsman in the world so
let's go through the massive list of
feeds that this blade has it is the only
blade in the entire series that has both
a supreme grade Rank and is a Black
Blade it is just insanely massive and
can cut through giant ice mountains with
ease it also delivered the first real
defeat of a straw hat in the entire
story and showed us just how under level
Luffy and Zorro were at that time and it
has been used in many legendary duels
with the likes of Shanks throughout the
years now that is undoubtedly an
impressive list of accomplishments but
oh wait there is even more mystery
surrounding the sword than you might
think because one thing you may not have
ever noticed are these strange markings
on yoru because these markings are
actually shockingly similar to these
markings that are on the empty throne in
marijuana I mean what when I first read
about this it completely blew my mind I
thought he might have worked for the
celestial dragons or maybe he just took
Euro from someone who did but whatever
the true answer is there's obviously
many more secrets this legendary sword
might hold about the one piece world but
as we get closer to the end of the story
many of Secrets like this are being
revealed and one of the most important
Secrets is the truth about devil fruit
so if you want to find out which of the
most overpowered devil fruits almost
broke one piece you can watch that video
right here Shanks for watching and I'll
see you in the next one